♪♪♪
>>> SHE'S THE ONE WHO MAKES THE
HOLIDAYS MERRY AND BRIGHT.
THE PERFECT GIFT, THE PERFECT
WRAPPING, THE PERFECT
EVERYTHING.
SO WHAT DO YOU GET THE WOMAN WHO
MAKES CHRISTMAS FOR CHRISTMAS?
THE GIFT EVERY WOMAN DESIRES, A
BEAUTIFUL CHARM FROM PANDORA.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> OH, IT'S ONE OF THESE.
IT'S A LITTLE COFFEE CUP.
>> I KNEW YOU WOULD.
>> WHAT?
>> I'M SORRY, DID YOU SAY YOU
LOVE IT?
>> I DO.
I LOVE IT.
>> AT PANDORA CHARMS WE TAKE ONE
LITTLE FACT ABOUT YOUR WIFE AND
TURN IT INTO JEWELRY.
IF IT'S A NOUN, IT'S A CHARM.
>> OH, IS IT A LITTLE DRESS?
>> YEAH, I NOTICE YOU WEAR
DRESSES.
>> IT HAS A PINK RIBBON ON IT.
FOR BREAST CANCER?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> PANDORA CHARMS SAY THE THINGS
YOU WANT TO TELL HER THE MOST.
LIKE I KNOW WHAT JOB YOU HAVE
AND THAT JOB IS NURSE.
OR, YOU LIKE DRINKING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OR THIS IS A DOG.
ONCE YOU BOUGHT A PANDORA
BRACELET YOU CAN GET HER ONE OF
THESE $60 WHATEVERS FOR EVERY
MOTHER'SDAY, ANNIVERSARY AND
BIRTHDAY FOR THE REST OF HER
NATURAL LIFE.
>> IT IS A COFFEE CUP, GREG GOT
IT FOR ME.
I GOT GREG A MOTORCYCLE.
>> I GOT US A THREESOME.
>> WOW.
>> YEAH.
>> PANDORA, COME BACK TO THE
MALL.
♪♪♪